where did this story come from you know
the all of the the the movies that I
make I intend to make in this you know
the genre it you know come from real
fears you know they have to start with
something that is something that scares
me I don't know why okay so I put a lot
of those things in there but you know
the the you know the thing that always
as a kid scared me was the idea of
seeing myself across the subway platform
after and you know there's this
underpass underneath the tracks and
seeing myself go into the underpass
across the the platform and sort of
wondering when I'm gonna come come out
and face myself and there's this feeling
of like there's this primal feeling with
the idea of the the doppelganger right
and I think it comes from this this
feeling like one of us must die you know
no dark it's just well you know
inherently right there's only enough
room for one of me here so there's
there's this existential threat that
comes there and so you know then trying
to figure out what's what is that why
does that always trigger me and you know
I started looking at you know ideas of
synchronicity and mythologies of
doppelgangers throughout history and you
know just about every culture has some
kind of doppelganger mythology and and
and and I sort of I I wanted to make
these this kind of like tribute to this
idea of our shadow self which is what
the doppelganger Monster tends to be
about this idea of what all these things
that we've suppressed in ourselves that
they're they're there and we don't face
them so this this idea really came into
focus for me when I thought got this
idea of the doppelganger family this
family of four and all of a sudden
the implications are just kind of
exponential when you say okay this is
not about my shadow self this is about
our shadow selves as a group and that
was like okay we got a we got to go on
this adventure and it's it sounds fun
how did you become to the project and
and and what was it like to be working
on screen after that first experience in
this project well while I was working on
Black Panther get out came out in the
cinema and it was the first movie that I
actually notated in my in my calendar to
go see and I went to see it opening
night and I just could not believe it
and so I pulled my cast mates from Black
Panther to watch it with me a second
time and I ended up watching it five
times in one month Wow I in every free
moment I was going to the cinema to see
this film again and again and each time
I would see something new and at the
conversations that came out of those
viewings were so rich and you know just
exchanging theories and observations and
everything it's a it was a kind of movie
that you just you took with you out of
the cinema and you lived with it you
know and so I remember thinking golly
I'd love to work with Jordan Pio one day
and played it very cool be clear and
Daniel Kaluga who wasn't get out and
also and black panther says to me
casually one day Oh Jordan Peele would
really like to be in touch with you can
I give him your email and I was like
what why are you asking you know give it
to him already and so we got in touch
I'm then after the movie was over we met
for a general meeting and you played it
cool because he said I'm writing
something you might be right for it or
you might not so it wasn't until a year
later that I actually just received a
script from my agent you know there was
no personal contact it just came with
the offer and I was like what and of
course I read it immediately
with the intention of saying yes and
then I read it and I realized oh my god
I get to work with Jordan Peele twice in
one movie and then we got on the phone
cuz I wanted to make sure that I
understood what he was going for you
know it's a very layered story and I
could tell from the page that there was
more than met the eye it was this
monster story and my shoulders are up
and I was so nervous just reading it I
invested immediately in this family and
I went on the ride but I could tell that
you know like and get out there was some
social commentary in it and you know
cinematic omage is being paid that I
needed to understand so I got on the
phone and we had a very lengthy and
detailed conversation that then led to
me saying of course I'm gonna do this
movie with you that's great
and Winston how'd you come to the
project and tell us about sort of your
first thoughts well my experience really
this is my voice well my experience
really mirrored Lupita's incredibly so I
was part of that group that she took to
see get out and we were all just sitting
there in awe of all the moments just
been like wow he's really Daniel is an
action star now you know our buddy you
know we're all just friends and we all
see each other as just people on set
especially for Black Panther was very
communal and we're going from seeing our
friend Daniel Kuya you know who was on
set like a week ago and we're looking at
the screen were like wow he's now an
action star he's now an icon oh my God
look at that moment he just saved
himself with cotton you know it's like
wow wow
so we left and spoke for maybe two or
three hours at a bar and just like dug
into this thing so I was just a big fan
and horror was a genre I never felt any
kind of attachment to because
the only way that I felt like I could
live in that space was through a the
approach of like scary movie where you
where you're making fun of the genre and
you're making fun of the tropes of like
y'all gonna leave me alone to go to find
the monsters really so I never felt like
I'd find my way in a wit up with a sense
of agency through that genre so I wasn't
attached until get out and it changed
the paradigm for me completely and then
at the Oscars I met Jordan and gosht you
know you could only be new one so I was
like hey I love you I didn't waste any
time I was like you're the man you know
everything and he calls maybe three
weeks later and there I was like I don't
even know what to make of this and he's
playing it cool on the phones like so
you you you married you got kids
I was hitting on oh no he didn't let me
break back there yeah and I he was like
I don't want a cloud or color this
experience for you in any way so I won't
tell you anything about the project I
want you to go home read it and let me
know if you're interested we I read it i
sat with it for like an hour just
thinking about all the themes you know
that I read on that page and everything
that you saw on screen was on that page
I think we just distilled it and
whittled it down as we went on and
throughout this process but everything
you saw was there the humor and Gabe was
present and you felt the function of
Gabe as the as the clown character as
the clown archetype you felt all those
functions throughout the script and as a
through-line
and we sat down we talked about how we
would represent masculinity in this and
how it's an opportunity to
have a lot of duality in Gabe's self you
know Gabe is both adhering to regular
ideas of what masculinity is like he
lives his life with a lens of the
patriarchy listen to me I'm the
breadwinner he performs his master he
lives his masculinity that way but the
performance of his self isn't as such he
is overly articulate he is not your
stoic cowboy so he's not just thinking
and brooding you know and he can be
silly and effective silly and you know
all these different things at once that
you don't really see with masculinity on
screen so we talked about some of those
things early and I knew that I was
walking into a really great
collaborative space because he started
sharing early you know so it was great
in terms of playing this character and
developing it for you these characters
not method but what was the process what
were you connected to most about the two
women you were playing hmm what I would
say is that it's not often that you get
one meaty role it's completely unheard
of to get to in one film and Jordan
Peele wrote this film with the intention
to have the story told from both women's
perspectives and that was such a rich
rich ground to grow from you know and
the intellectual what just like boxing
match that had to happen in my head
between us you know as we went along
making this film was
just it was it it tried me like nothing
else but I what I appreciated was that
first of all he wrote an extremely
intelligent story and entrusted it to me
and you know and in in that it forced me
to rise to levels that I didn't even
know we're possible for me you know so
it's it these are these are roles that
piques my interest and tore me down and
built me back up you know and what I've
always wanted at the end of the day as
an act of what I always want to do is
illuminate the the the the the story
that I've been given you know to find
the most human representation of the
words on the page
and so I just felt like in the creator
was such a deep respect and such a
empathetic viewpoint that I wanted those
things to be emulated in the way that I
that I played these two women and I and
I think it's like so important for us to
recognize the duality in human nature
and that's at the core of this story you
know this idea that you know there is a
light and dark in each of us it was just
so exciting to play that you know and to
and to find the most the distinctions
between the two and the things that
brought them together and just that that
emotional tension and how to embody it
and and and and express it ladies and
gentlemen please join me in Thank You
Jordan pill Lupita Nyong'o and Winston
do